anyone welcome up to this video playing
the hourly super blitz arena on leeches
this is three miniatures I'm playing
school 2016 so much more theoretical
opening 95 it's a somewhat weird thing
to play them okay right position is of
course very solid hmm what's the point
keeper taking eight eggs two straight
stuff okay can play it's probably still
equal ish
thanks with the G porn okay okay night
take c3 evolving a palm right or f2 for
that method repeat this is more more
logical I think and I'm a pawn up for
basically nothing he has some weaknesses
on top of it so what to do a five a four
is an idea along I can also just now
place the Queenie reaction I don't mind
him playing this to be honest a5 a4 gets
simpler to play even though I'm a little
bit weak only only 7 pawn that's
definitely true I can put the Queen to
f6 though okay
he allows me to play a 4 which I should
be glad to see take this first and now
we have maybe
engage form to click Queen to f6
okay the ending would be really nice
she's got a number of weaknesses of this
if he takes I have the a file okay and I
can now go into the second ring before I
would have to take then looks it all
know doesn't do that on okay in a couple
of options to get just go here attending
group t3 so he goes here and now I was
thinking e5 maybe g5 first fix the F
pawn and then go five takes takes and
then I can slowly push my way forward
yeah I can actually like see I can play
for d5 but I can also go okay he just
jettison to this pawn for nothing so
I'll take it
h3 on yeah this is probably easiest just
take take the other pawns h2 we will
play play the book I can take here
though now okay get to c4 pawn
so yeah just just d5s completely enough
the ones are just very quick just float
in the sea point I still have 19 seconds
it's quite comfortable still
hmm okay so he resigned
why won't he have two points it seems
that most people deserved I know I want
too much too much stress here just play
play some some games I considered also
to do the 5 minute 5 minute hour the
arena but yeah so let's play some before
in this tournament
ok it's the only move by a novice cook
should be fine more or less let's see
what band of brothers is playing play
into some interesting line that I
recently analyzed called G form the tech
not easy for black to handle this kind
of situation especially not in a
3-minute game
one g5 is coming that's an interesting
choice but I can take it
Queen e5 is an interesting move now I
didn't know if he had no it didn't seem
that he had this on the radar when he
was playing g5 yeah yeah I have a really
quick development it looks a little bit
like yeah black black didn't didn't play
such as some moves that he was allowed
to play so let's see little bit lucky
past sometimes queen h8 now's on the
agenda that it's an almost immediate win
check Bishop back Bishop d6 mmm looks
pretty bad I'm not sure if he has a good
move here actually
97 so that he has got Knight f8 oh I can
still check ok now that was the idea I
have Bishop age 3 just to keep the tempo
up I think I'll do that it's still
pretty awkward now check check where
does he go he has to go back into the
eighth rank and then I have to check
again so it's pretty awkward if there's
something else though no I mean there
probably is but this this is good so I
also can just take the knight I just
recognize that let's just grab this
piece and then threatening Queen f3
check and then retreating the bishop
which is a good thing this unpinning can
be very very annoying so check
he has to go back and then I can move
the bishop he's a ticking yeah
he's attacking between roopd window is
good on that I can also play a chick on
h8 and give up my a one look but I don't
really see why I should do that okay
here I can cancel just cancel long just
a four piece and there's 9f5 and so I
coming then just go back d5 is hanging
oh okay let's look behind again I didn't
want to buzzer can just play some some
real next games can tweak on it's
immediately shown that I'm playing for
win here with the with the Dutch don't
knows I just had this idea maybe to play
cookie 5 and we take some time
yeah this is not a bad position I think
with this big Center it cannot be
terrible actually
so I'm opening up the diagonal and have
95 on the radar or 95 ah so he wants to
trade now be three years attacked so
look you two I take and take v3 I think
I should be fine um here with the
default control just attack the bishop
and just somehow this doesn't look quite
right
93 and I can do 93 years let's just
improve the position a little bit what
will he do croelick lacking in one roopd
to where this idea the IDM let us help
him even though I mean I still have more
space on
Kings is really before is probably okay
or this first okay I should try to
somehow
oops just puts it forward interesting
didn't expect this to happen okay not
bad pro it maybe I should have taken
though now that I think of it that
probably that would have been better
looking better
okay again not a big deal though the see
pawns are weakest for both players and
for maybe 96 then otherwise f4 would be
interesting can involve space
[Music]
97 that actually is a bit awkward we're
doing this set an idea I don't know it
looks a bit weird I want to try
something at least it could be a wrong
idea
posing posing more problems for me than
for anybody else okay so I would and
neat you put the knight on to e5 to d3
that would be the idea so came here and
now try to bring the Knight to e5 to d3
is the thing can I do this like here
Coffee has to doesn't I thought you
would maybe play 91 so I think I'm
getting up to here I got somewhere and I
was definitely some risk involved it's a
full night
yeah good defense by Kent by Kendrick on
okay I'm a little bit behind
hey maybe I should be look good
nah Moustafa gala what is most of her
playing for I'm telling him no so I'm
going to bow temple area with 15 points
whoa how am I going to catch this guy
that looks difficult maybe each six
quite close to h4 it and come in such a
position white normally tries to not
encourage any pong pushes I mean I'm not
saying that this is great for liver
donors it's just a little bit uncommon
yeah point six or night eggs
can do that this is maybe not so bad
it's a bit strange but I think I can
play a five pretty quickly and this is a
reasonably active especially with the
night the night only five is very active
he has the check but but I don't know
I'm feared as much okay now I can take
or play F or F for or this one actually
let's do this
this is an interesting move takes pawn
takes is pretty aggressive with the King
pawn and everything
wow wow that looks that looks weird it
opens up his his on one position him os4
I was brutal puso to himself
you have a checksum corner yeah 93 wins
the exchange but if I sit here
I'm additionally threatening work to g8
winning immediately
No let's end of game Wow 20 points for
temporary Oh what the heck
it's like be joking every single game
maybe guess is probably the way to go
here to to Windows tournaments okay so
chicken king stripping
Oh mate next move Wow it's [ __ ]
everything and he has known as much
quicker and much quicker than me okay
and I need gains 1003 right last one
here and go to old Italian castle Shore
not be nice yes this is nice for black
me immediately getting something going
on the kingside what it's a piece I will
have two black shark on a7s bolo gun
coined it ok takes B son what what the
beep
don't tell me this is actually somewhat
working for wider ads it's crazy
you just blunder this bishop and then
then the summer works great we should be
second e7b should be five-year Knight f5
is somewhat which is somewhat working
under liver now somewhat murky edges
it's just chaos
you'll be shoved e5c only move otherwise
it's just over 9 85 Queen before c6 is
not clear really isn't I'm threatening
rook HB 8 winning the Queen so he has to
play bisciotti fun ok
yeah let's open this bishop up on a7
completely bonkers position but nobody
understands anything but I'm huge
material
now I know he's running out of checks
okay come on
okay 16.0 has got one extra point
temporary oh I will probably need to be
paired again so I would help would be
helpful
squad 2016 and it is my first round
opponent but seeing okay in place this
line which is not really it's not really
working
not really playable
even though yeah it is still somewhat
chaotic in now just take it or not I'm
probably developing is good it's not
quite clear how he develops this piece
of sample and so a three four before but
I mean we cannot take and with before
I'm going to keep everything you will
have to go back to but to date
the 195 the tempo I guess okay auntie em
yeah probably probably Queen d2 again
tempo and now threatening G for winning
the night and so I asked to spend the
move again um yam should be three I
guess funny position like it's just
completely toasted already so take here
all this should be five is also move I
wonder
you will probably care for next year
when I take he will cancel my it's no
way to completely kill them on it should
be five Bishop d7 is still somewhat
somewhat playable yeah I think I will
just take take d6 but I can take here
though it is possible
ninety-six Bishop a6 also okay it's
pretty miserable I can take on c3 but
this is well
here you can take one c3 yeah two-time
poison it's not so great
repeat like to get c4 in Bishop h3 look
at for this my work doesn't work I think
unless I'm blundering stuff I have
issued a five you can play hey
[Music]
ridiculous just can just play Bishop f5
and turn yeah but doesn't do it okay 95
just so not even allowing any weakening
but weird
look Fe for windage sixes the idea the
Queen shot at one age six oh I don't
think it will last much longer
can almost prove 95 okay Oh Templar you
lost the game Mario Mario the key would
be get some probably some trash semi
tirage semi to rush this is an extremely
comfortable variation for white like the
black ass blacks lost already here
that's it for the Queen it is very nice
for white in even if black plays it okay
with sometimes you have if this stock
more no you're not continuing this stuff
really wow wow yeah this is the kind of
things I always drive me crazy it's not
so just for the tournament it's not
grade em you just waste time with those
totally decided games
I could have taken look the eight that
would be would have been pretty quick
okay so actually taking the lead now
Templar is probably still playing so
twenty five minutes left and I just
wonder is there anybody else Pro not new
seventy staying within classical stuff
let's take the King's gambit that's a
good line Knight f6 what why this is
really it's not promising at all can you
cheat on c3 or play 93 it should have
taken on c3 and played Bishop d6
actually it would have been back on I'm
not happy how I played us to be honest I
didn't play as well he's getting much
much more than he should have gotten
hmm hmm don't like it
I don't know why it's fine
I completely misplayed this that's not
good
I don't I don't think I'm lost or
anything but in why it should be such as
verse in the Kings gambit and it's not
happening and especially the way he
played it should be worse pretty bad so
let's get over the chick
yeah White has the better minor piece
here with the bishop and more active
pieces so he is better just attacking
this so it's simple and good I know if
this looks not good that doesn't look
good but moving moving the F pawn is
also pretty awful
okay B 525 check is a very cheap trick
[Music]
it's not at all yet him I can he can
control I didn't want that I thought I
can just play now okay ma'am
that was bad but okay I didn't want to
make sure actually no anyway and it was
bad I just made I just completed his
plate his opening
I should have taken on c3 and played
Bishop d6 keeping the pawn for a long
time it's just better for black okay not
a big deal Rosen very fun for a change
but see what he does let's go for the
open and this line earlier you know you
know I think in a bullet tournament or
but what's that bully tournament anyway
this is a funny line where white is very
comfortable actually in fact what it
looks like it sucks or like get into
this so quickly
okay in botsko f4 push the night maybe
Knight to c6 here's an idea for him yeah
I wonder should I keep this I should
actually keep it yeah this is a good
idea in IG v it's a can be really
irritating from work oh let's not react
to that at all
isn't that pretty awful there should be
two stuff f5 should be too right f6
looks forced oh okay so I v5 I have to
check night h7 it's got so many tempting
moves night f7 or f5 f5 is also good now
he cannot take this 95 and then 9 f7 is
totally killing
that's opening up Bishop to g5 so if I
play here he has to go clean e7 - I mean
the Queen has no other square and then
Bishop g5 wins the Queen yeah so he just
gives me the Queen and what's going on
anyway but I'm just a queen now that's
good okay people just never resign even
a queen down
it's really age there's a huge factor in
those tournaments yeah
people resigning at a decent moment or
just controlling on for a minute or two
a you just stalled I mean it's not like
I mean it just takes a couple of moves
to win this position even though I am up
the million pieces probably no big
difference we're how you play it's a
queen top in c4 is quicker problem
I know much the same just okay cliff
resigned
like two minutes ago right whatever
it also harms their own chances I never
understand that what the point is and
they don't get a point and I mean just
playing the game and score points for
yourself and just not know okay so the
Ponciano
the sauce d5 is the most aggressive
reply and if things go well they go
really well like here you just stuff up
for absolutely nothing
okay ninety-five I shouldn't have run
into a bishop your voice now on this
agenda would let's be let's be quick
about it but still attacking a look take
here castle so even if he gets a pawn
back and I'm sure I'm not sure that he
can do that but his whole position is
just immensely
weakened I mean H to f2 and so on and
while my six pawns are perfectly placed
he will get you formed that's a given no
it's not a given now we actually gives
me this so take it I will take it if you
insist like that
and okay so when the second-ranked or e3
I know III is probably one good possible
move
maybe Queen f3 though Queen f3 could be
a move now it makes sense okay
he still has issues with the skin so
would be one Queen here I want to be on
light squares here for Queen h3
sometimes you create is also around the
corner I can actually do the same now
that's a good one good move to get into
I'm also wondering if there are some
direct meeting ideas 94 492 you know why
not I also have 95 maybe sometimes if a
goes King G 195 okay now I don't have a
maid okay I want to get rid of my own
background issues okay hmm
[Music]
chicken on h3 let's see I think I don't
want to trade rather keep it on the
board head threaten h4 and there wasn't
a tactical direct technical trick at
least I didn't see any each form for
what I know and I want me to play h4 is
not so great oh okay I can take it I can
just direct the ticket why do I only get
two points the whole time why don't I
get four at least once in a while okay I
don't know what it is okay Alex dude
I've got black again so let's play
sounds solid og3 mmmm okay
it's very classical stuff Queen b3 M so
typical idea don't do it okay I think
I'll take three sorry if my voice is a
bit failing me I think he wants to play
some evil stuff yeah that is definitely
possible okay maybe I have to do this
play form quick 26:58 he has a weakness
on d3 he might play Bishop b1
he am not even back to g2 it's an
interesting thought Queen c2 is also
made threat very interesting yeah that
is actually a pretty good idea I think
maybe I have to oh really I mean okay
you will get with someone I know I get
that but
hmm quite surprised p.m. checking here
you should see one let's look see for
our it's just a double attack and they
had Bishop f2 in some cases sorry my
voice is not good
hmm I think you just had a good position
with we should see to wall I don't know
the normal move it wasn't quite
necessary okay cancel just an exchange
up
let's see I can take most of yeah that
could have been a problem that game I
think I wasn't in some it was definitely
good for him if you would have not given
me the material all on some temp Larry
oh I think just left the tournament it
seems
you also heard an early lead and then
lost again okay I'm seven minutes south
sorry seven points behind
so Mustafar gala let's go before again
and see what happens
it goes for modern defense I'm going for
quick quick f-4e five stuff not sure
this is good in this particular position
but I've looked
I've checked this recently and you can
play combinations of this age 3 f4
Bishop e3 and it is quite and quite
dangerous of like I'm not sure about the
specific position though 93 years good
development move can I definitely play
e5 I may be before now huh okay didn't
do it okay
let's just centralize him and play this
position which should be comfortable f6
probably is no didn't do it
f6 looked like a good option I'm just
castling long okay but g4 is is coming
just on the next move and you don't want
to take you for I mean definitely or not
it seems like he wants to do it
let's go fantastic we should pair so I
am stopping Knights you for stuff and
over loop this one okay it's still so
good for white but I mean black still s
rubbish g7 measurement and so on but
shouldn't have gifted him the bishop air
bag if it so quickly maybe as high as
now no no
I wonder I should put it should I put
this here you it's not bad
see forward you have to go back on it
says some trickery okay so if I take
this and go night to d4 okay
excited still irritating me it does
never want it since he never wants to
play it wait
let's not be too quick here let's go
down
I'm just winning at five and that should
be a really good pond to win and he even
has to watch out for checkmate Mac okay
there's always this woman calm always
this one and while he doesn't threaten
anyway anyway so push the edge form no
it's made
let's chick meet I can actually pre move
this wall okay Tom that's the guy
following the guy behind me so I should
better lost lose this one but this might
not count anyway right it could be too
late not entirely sure about the system
yeah it can go c6 here also I'm never
quite sure what to do here I have to see
form
Wow they're actually very tempting to go
for a direct kill not play anything slow
with such a passive setup maybe it's
making fun of me because that tournament
is already over as possible
I mean by the depth expedition is not in
what could so I can just take okay Queen
that is this then the knight coming but
I can take yes pawn takes Queen f3 is
just landing on h2 so yeah can I do
something better than and then we can
actually trade stuff
I probably don't have have something
better
Oh gauge 1m and here he gets a lost lost
ending Knight f4 is actually this is
actually a little bit bit of pressure so
probably I'll cover this and just go
with the King pawn offers a draw
no not gifting you my reading pods
always said unrated anyway I don't know
if it's underrated I might do this but I
don't give away points after this game
was such a one-sided affair
nice defending this quite well iam
Bishop to b4 is annoying
[Music]
Wow I have really miss played that
I can t define merely great
it's amazingly bad disposition great
[Laughter]
that's really great absolutely great
here in Roxy for I mean really have to
struggle him to be somewhat in the game
gets a look at the upon as well now I
will be the sun-times II absolutely
easily okay okay wow it's bad I'm
spoiling this at the end yeah
that's really bad like I'm I don't know
did that count waiting why's the last
game I have no idea probably yes I mean
can I sort of see my last games I think
I can
last kings this is somewhere right now
where is that I gave see against it says
- 28
even though you did it subtract it it
did yeah so I lost this I lost it was
four points then yeah I mean okay it was
okay for me that I better continue
because they were a totally winning
position but then then I played it
really terribly and rosters even okay so
that was a good tournament oh and I
think quite quite entertaining yeah I
hope you liked it
I'll be back soon bye while